let's talk about blood vessels
i'm going to talk to you about the
different types of blood vessels that
there are and we're going to see if we
can come up with some general patterns
so let's start with the
let's say we take a blood vessel out of
your body and we
examine it under a microscope it would
look something like this where you have
the middle and call that the lumen and
right outside of the lumen you have
cells
and these cells are going all the way
around the lumen
and they're the first type of cell that
any blood would interact with right
because that's right immediately outside
of the lumen
and on the other side of the cells in
the back side of the cells if you think
of the lumen as the front side
is a little line i'm going to draw here
to represent
protein
that sits there
and acts as a scaffold kind of like
keeping all the cells in place so you
have all these endothelial cells
endothelial cells and then you have that
little uh
base membrane like a thin line of
membrane called the basement membrane
that keeps everything
from falling out of place
and the thing that's in the basement
membrane is mostly protein so think
about things like collagen which you can
find in bones and your gums that same
protein is actually
lining
all of these blood vessels that are in
your body
and together the basement membrane and
endothelial cells they make up a
layer
called the tunica
writing it nice and big intima
they make up a layer called the tunica
intima and that's kind of the
the word we use because tunica comes
from the word for coat or cloak and
intima is kind of the intimate layer the
intimate coding of the vessels so tunica
intima
now right outside of this is another
layer
and i'm going to draw that here in red
and this would be a layer of muscle so
imagine these little lines represent
smooth muscle cells
so this would be muscle and this would
be the layer of tunica called tunica
media
or middle
and the most important thing here is
that there's smooth muscle in this layer
smooth muscle
and finally on the very outside you have
another layer
and i'm going to draw it as a yellow
line
and this yellow line
represents more protein
this is another layer of protein just
like the basement membrane but
different composition of proteins but
again you see actually a lot of collagen
just as before and some other proteins
as well and this is called the tunica
externa
for external layer
tunica externa actually another word
that they sometimes use
for this is called adventitia
adventitia
so you might see that work too
and the really interesting thing about
the tunica externa is that you actually
on the large vessels
you find that they need blood to supply
themselves and so some of these large
vessels
have little blood vessels
on them
now you might think well does this just
go on endlessly you know vessels
with vessels on them and then those
little vessels have more vessels on them
and so on and so forth actually no
it's just the large vessels that have
this so
you sometimes not always see what's
called vasa
vasurum and this is
kind of a fancy
name for it but they're little blood
vessels on blood vessels
which i always thought was kind of a
cool thing
so the tunic externa has the blood
vessels and it also has
nerve endings
and i'm not going to actually draw that
in because it would be kind of hard to
show that but
nerve
endings actually
can be in that layer
in that
tunica external layer so you've got
three layers each of them has some
pretty cool things in them and now i
thought what we would do is we'd go
and think about each vessel type and how
this could look for that vessel so let's
start with the
veins and i'll do the veins over here
so let's say you have a vein
on the inside it has that
tunica intima layer and i'm not going to
draw the cells out because now you know
what that represents that purple line
represents the endothelial cells and the
basement membrane
and you also have a smooth muscle
layer so kind of a red line
to represent tunica media
and veins have a tunica externa
a third layer so veins kind of follow
this general pattern they have these
three layers and they're pretty
straightforward in terms of following
exactly what i just talked about
fair enough
now arteries let me do a different color
for arteries let's say
red
i think of arteries in two different
groups so i think of
large
and middle sized arteries
a little differently than i think about
small
arteries or arterials
and you'll see that these small arteries
and arterials actually look quite
similar to one another so let's start
with the large and middle sized arteries
so there you have let's say
an inside
and
then on the outside of that in the
tunica media layer you start seeing a
difference
from the veins you see that it's much
larger
much larger
and in the vein you just had kind of a
thin layer of smooth muscle here you
have a nice large layer of smooth muscle
and in addition to having these smooth
muscle cells
in the large and middle arteries you
have an interesting new thing you have
something called elastin protein
an elastin
is going to be in here
and this is a protein that helps make
these
very elastic
right because they're going to have such
high pressures
that they have to be able to not break
when these pressures are going through
so this elastin
this green elastin protein
helps make the arteries more elastic
more elastic
for high pressures
for high
pressures
and i'll write p for pressures
so that's what the middle layer looks
like and of course you still have your
outer layer as before
okay so you've seen
one key difference now
right with these large
and
middle sized arteries
okay now let's go to the small arteries
and the arterials
so here let's start out with a lumen
you have that as before
and you also have a large tunica media
so unlike the vein the tunica media and
the arteries in both types of arteries
is actually quite large
except here instead of having
elastin
in this area you have just tons and tons
of muscle
lots of muscle
so they're very very
strong in the sense that
you can actually very easily squeeze
down on the
lumen if you wanted to
by having all this muscle contract
and that makes sense because we know
that the arterials
look at all that muscle the arterials
are actually going to be the ones that
are going to
create resistance
so here
you have a lot of
muscle
and this is to help create lots of
resistance
if you need it to change your blood
pressure so that's why the small
arteries and arterials are really
helpful in squeezing down and changing
blood pressures
and on the outside they as before have
that layer of
tunica externa
and this again is where the
nerve endings go and where the blood
vessels or the vasova zorum go
so that's where that layer is
okay
and you might be thinking well there's
got to be one more uh
cell or one more vessel type and there
is and that's the capillary so let me
draw the capillary i guess i'll do that
over here
and the capillary
is actually going to look different from
all this other
stuff that we've done because the
capillaries are actually really really
unique
in the sense that unlike what we had for
the
veins and the arteries
this is down to the single cell level
right so you still have a lumen
but on the outside instead of having a
lot of endothelial cells you actually
have
at times
one cell
one cell
will actually
form the entire wall of the tube so you
actually have a cell traveling within a
cell almost like the cell is giving
the little red blood cells floating
through a big hug or something like that
so that that capillary looks actually
quite different as you can see from the
other things that we've drawn the veins
in the arteries but i want you to just
take a look at this again and see the
the key differences between the veins
and the arteries the vein follows the
general pattern but the larger middle
arteries have a lot of elastin in the
tunica media and the small and
small arteries and arterials have a lot
of muscle in that tunica media